Oh looks like he's getting his ass
kicked by a ghost when you're this drunk
life is a field sobriety test
[Music]
William H Macy's in the yard again
you're drunk
oh wait
counterpoint is that the Preakness
Stakes which is the Kentucky Derby's
inbred cousin getting pelted with beer
cans atop a port-a-potty is still better
than stepping foot inside of one so
close when I blurt anything that's how
small his whiskey dick is hard to say
who should be more ashamed of themselves
if you're secretly filming strangers
from your stall it's time for you to do
a little soul-searching notice it starts
out like every other video we get from
England with a drunk and a pub either he
lost a bet or the English version of The
Biggest Loser is way more intense than
ours what a shot can a dart to the spine
do damage
apparently not when your muffin top is
made of Kevlar thanks mom
[Applause]
[Music]
you